it's only the middle of October but
winter weather has arrived in Berlin the
refugees outside the central reception
center are cold they have to wait here
each day to be registered and that could
take days or even weeks really cold I
don't have this one and I go look one
this very problem I think Germany has
expected just Syria maybe to come but so
many people are coming here the refugees
in Berlin have to wait outside many even
choose to sleep here aid organizations
fear that people could die from the cold
every day more refugees arrived in the
capital as many as used to come in an
entire year the authorities are trying
to remedy the situation this Bank
building has long been vacant soon it
will be turned into a new headquarters
for processing refugees with all the
necessary offices under one roof I'm
avoidance a fan here spoke to an off to
bountiful even brilliant light we're
trying to develop a system that has
never existed before in Germany about
zoo after a not least a business but for
many in Berlin this new system is coming
much too late people here say the
government took too long to realize that
the number of refugees is only getting
bigger not smaller